Oh
you know one of the things that's
interesting about human beings is that
we talk about living in the moment we
want to live an experience yeah at the
same time when it experiences rapturous
it feels as though the experience is
owed a poem rendered in real time the
experience is absolutely captured then I
think one of the quotes that really kind
of distills the human desire to capture
the world to take a picture of it the
snapshot it and make it fit so that it
can hold them in a kind of stasis is the
quote that says to see the world in a
grain of sand to see heaven in a wild
flower hold infinity in the palm of your
hand and eternity in an hour right that
desire to capture and arrest
impermanence Faulkner used to talk about
the writers futile yet noble efforts to
fit the world inside of the sentence to
capture the world encode it and store it
inside of a page the photographer tries
take a still frame of the universe the
filmmaker who distills truth twenty four
times per second and through persistence
of vision and psychic continuity can
externalize the human mind and capture
the world on celluloid or the engineers
who built the Hubble Space Telescope
that maybe can mainline space and time
through the optic nerve as Ross Anderson
says inducing kind of ontological
awakening in the receivers mind the
person who looks at the deep field
photograph as he has a
with what is all of these different
technologies all of these different
tools that we have created to capture
ending old reality as it slims to arrest
that that is the human condition that's
what we do
you